[Street view of the front of a building with a walled front yard. There is a gate.]
[A woman dressed in dark clothing with a cape and headcovering walks up the street and tries to enter one gate.]
[The woman goes to a second entrance where the gate is open and goes into the building.]
[The interior of the front yard is shown. There are walls covered with vines and a tree.]
[A woman is shown crossing the yard and checking on something that is steaming on the ground.]
[The interior has people seated and standing. There are men in uniform and women in suits and skirts.]
[There is an American flag on the wall. The wall is covered with masks of faces.]
[Closer view of one of the men in uniform and a woman who is watching him light a cigarette.]
[The man takes off a prosthetic chin and mouth. It fastens onto his face with strings that go around his ears.]
[The man replaces the prosthetic and turns to face and speak to the woman, and she to him.]
[A woman paints a prosthetic chin.]
[The prosthetic chin is fitted to a plaster mask to check for fit.]
[The prosthetic chin covers a severe deformity of the face.]
[A man wearing a white coat works on a plaster mask. A woman assists him.]
[The man trims some pieces of a mold taken from a mask. He is talking as he brushes the edges.]
[The man hands the pieces to a woman who is piecing them together. She holds the assembled mold up to the camera.]
[The man holds up the plaster mask and then takes off the prosthetic piece which is covering a damaged chin.]
[The man carefully looks at the mask and is talking as he holds it up.]
[He shows the mask with the damaged portion once again hidden by the prosthetic.]
[A woman shows a mold for a prosthetic ear which is attached to a frame with wire. She uses the frame to hold the ear suspended within a bowl.]
[She turns some knobs on a small machine nearby and closes the top of the machine.]
[Another woman is molding a prosthetic nose.]
[A woman is painting a prosthetic nose that a man is wearing. He is seated in front of her and is in uniform.]
[The man and woman are talking as she works. The plaster molds are hanging on the wall behind them.]
[Two women and a man are discussing and working on a mold. The man removes the prosthetic from the mold to adjust it.]
[The man adjusts the piece and tries it on the plaster mask again.]
[They seem happy with the fit.]
[A man with severe injuries to his face removes a covering he wears over the injury to his face.]
[He is fitted with a prosthetic piece that covers the area around his eyes and his nose.]
[The prosthetic maker adjusts the fit of the prosthetic which attaches around the man's ears.]
[He removes the prosthetic again to make further fitting adjustments, then replaces it.]
[End of movie]